he is the former commissioner Major
League Baseball and he has a new book
it's entitled for the good of the game
the inside story of the surprising and
dramatic transformation of Major League
Baseball now available online and Weber
books are sold
is Bud Selig the former commissioner
joins us on the program commissioner
thanks for joining us I was wondering if
you became the acting commissioner in
1992 what would the 2019 Bud Selig tell
the 1992 Bud Selig well that's a great
question
I didn't realize for about four or five
months that I really had inherited as
the book says a blanking mess and I say
that we had no labor deal our economics
I say damn we were back in the Polo
Grounds ever still they that's the last
time they had changed account I didn't
realize how bad it was but I don't know
I guess sir what I would I would have
said to myself is don't do what they've
done for so long you've got to adjust
these problem they're gonna be painful
you're gonna get killed you're gonna get
ripped apart on certain things and I
learned that over the years but I guess
that's the advice I would have given
myself anything off limits in this book
when you started no absolutely not
none zero what was the most fun neurotic
you know and everybody tells me how
candid it is and I appreciate that
because I tried to be I just I did a lot
of dictation to Rodgers and Richard
justice and and Charles Steinberg and
and you know I just told it the way it
was I took any responsibility that I
thought I should have and there have
been a lot of myths that have grown up
relative to the steroid thing and I
wanted to clear that up but no I am and
I feel good about it what was your
favorite thing to talk about
you know favorite is well my favorite
thing to talk about of course is my
family my mother and father daughters
wife and a lot of stuff to all that the
Milwaukee stuff is good although that
too is painful in terms of not getting a
team that was just five and a half years
of a lot of disappointment and I guess
the thing I wanted to talk about most
even though the economic changes are the
most important was the steroid thing Dan
and because I thought there was so much
misinformation out there but and and I
was gonna be as blunt as could be and I
think I worked were steroids good for
the game in any way no no zero they were
bad for their health bad for the
integrity didn't help attendants tenants
after the mcguire social 98 went down in
99 I need all these theories about well
the owners have liked it because it was
good and I never heard an owner in a
meeting or privately with me ever
suggested that they were bad they are
bad and a lot of sports and lot of
sports people try to for the disguise
what the real problems are you can't do
that and I had a lot of players as I
said in the book who didn't take him who
came to me and remember this Dan and I
you know you and I had conversations
about this way back when yeah Dan it was
a subject of collective bargaining for
somehow and I don't wanna I mean it
doesn't look I'll give Don Ferrentino a
discredit they were public about it
anybody who followed shouldn't have been
surprised yes I banned him in the minor
leagues in 2004 the old one season but I
could do that unilaterally the rest was
one of the
most tense difficult negotiations have
lasted many years that I was involved in
I can't imagine I I'm sure that you had
this was crystallized to you of what it
was doing to the game and you had guys
who were doing things they shouldn't
have been doing getting records being
honored
but here's Hank Aaron who to me is one
of the you know the true dignitaries and
one of the most underrated players in
the history of the game when you had to
honor if you want to use that word Barry
Bonds for being the all-time homerun
King
if that doesn't hit home to you I don't
know if anything else in that steroid
era would have hit home how did that
feel well it says it in the early part
of the book it didn't feel good at all
it's one of the most difficult no I had
a go and you know that Hank Aaron and I
have been really close friends for 62
years now in fact I saw him in Atlanta
last week and we sat and talked about
some of this stuff as we always do but
how did it feel not very good and you
know who called me on a lot on that trip
I don't know if I say this in the book
or not almost on a daily basis Henry
Aaron just to make sure that I was doing
okay he's comforting you know a lot of
people said are the only reason he's
negative about it is because of his
relationship with Henry that's not true
how did Hank feel about bonds breaking
that record like he always does he
accepted it he didn't say much he was
quiet and I talked about it when the
giants called me and asked for Hank to
cut a video when Barry okayed he didn't
want to do it but he and I talked about
it and it died it's a fat guy he would
tie if he was on the show I said Henry
and in your entire life since I've known
you
it's back to 1958 you've always done the
right thing just cut something and he
did and it was really good and I'm glad
he did it I want you to be a baseball
fan not a commissioner
we allow me to ask you questions based
on you just being a baseball fan not a
commissioner I will totally who do you
consider the all-time homerun King well
I've never really answered that but but
I will say this to my mind even though
bonds holds the record and I said
records are records I think you know how
I feel about Henry era so Henry earns
the old-time homerun King in your
opinion yes would you vote for Barry
Bonds as a fan that's one I will not
answer because what I've said is I did
everything I could do I am you know push
remember this Danny I don't have to tell
you this baseball Natalie didn't have a
drug testing program we went to the
cocaine era serious problem and in the
80s Pittsburgh drugged Joe twenty-nine
guys get convicted for go to jail and
they couldn't get a drug Pope so I'm
proud of where we are but I'm gonna let
the writers and decide that they can
decide yeah but it's a baseball fan I
you know Barry Bonds shouldn't be in the
Hall of Fame then if he cheated I mean
there's I understand that same as Roger
Clemens you don't you don't answer no I
don't answer yeah you know I don't know
if it's more when people think of your
tenure there is it more about steroids
or is it more about Pete Rose because it
it you know it feels like every single
year steroids come up and Pete Rose
comes up at the Hall of Fame which one
did you go tired of more answering
questions about I did something about
the steroid thing and I did what I
thought was right about Pete Rose but I
want to say this to you and I try to say
this in the book the baseball period
that I was the Commissioner especially
the last 15 or 20 years it was really
the golden era in terms of attendance
revenue everything else did so I don't
agree with you I don't agree with the
premise of that question what I would
say to you is we were at a billion - in
92 and we were at 11 or 12 billion when
I left and so you say well about I know
I don't agree with that at all I'd hear
about the petros not much and a steroid
thing and we did what no other sport
does water says we have the best program
in America you have a commissioner
you're missing you're missing you know
you're taking my words out of context
here you ran a great business I'm
talking about the questions that you
were always asked people didn't go boy I
can't wait to talk to you about revenue
here they wanted to talk about headlines
you did you ran a great wild card
interleague play the pennant races the
Pete Rose thing was not much really
I met with Pete you know Johnny Bench
and Mike Schmidt and my friend Joe
Morgan brought him there and that was it
and outside of that it was yeah he came
to Cooperstown but and even stopped
doing that after awhile by the way yeah
I'm glad
as for the steroid thing when we've made
our first deal in ode to and a better
one in O six and a better one in 11 and
then I met a better one afterward I
think what I did our fans start and they
told me so is we had dealt with the
problem dad we didn't I mean nobody
denied the existence of the problem we
did it the book is for the good of the
game the inside story and surprising
dramatic transformation a major league
baseball now available online and
wherever books are sold we're talking to
the former commissioner Bud Selig it
just feels like there's more information
there with Pete than you've ever let out
because I've said before and I talked to
Peter Gammons about this it's almost as
if you'd sheet in grad school I can't
take away from your undergrad I can't
take away from Pete as a player but if
Pete was betting as a player which I
think he was that's why you would not
put him in the Hall of Fame
that's their I think that when Peter
Ueberroth and then Bart Giamatti and
then he had John Dowd and then Fay
Vincent I think all the information came
out I've read it over and over and it
was all released publicly so the fact
that he gambled on his team when he was
the manager of the Cincinnati Reds do
you need any more well he told me that
story
he I was on my show and he said I bet on
us to win every game yeah what does that
tell you he's not a good better look I
don't want you to misconstrue what I'm
saying you ran a great business I'm just
saying from the perspective of people
asking you these questions it felt like
steroids and peeping I never got much
people's okay it just felt like people
were waiting for for a headline out of
that or that Pete was somehow going to
get in the Hall of Fame which I said if
he gets in
it'll be posthumously it'll never be
during your tenure
it'll be never you'll you promised Bart
Giamatti I believe or you know basically
said I if Bart suspended him and I'm not
gonna put him you know getting the
opportunity instead never had I never
had a chance to do that because he died
so suddenly and then Bart and I were
extremely close there's no doubt about
that you know best piece of sports
memorabilia you have autographed
pictures of Williams DiMaggio and Aaron
a lot of stuff here though I got to
think about that's a great question but
they mean a lot to me you still go and
have your hot dog for lunch I'm gonna do
that about 15 I love that you would
listen when you went to go get your hot
dog or your wife was your spy and she'd
say
you know I wish you well and hopefully
it's the memoir that you wanted to tell
and you know it's it's gonna be what
you're known for yeah you certainly saw
a lot of things a lot of things and and
you know I go back and I tell people you
know whenever they would be critical of
you and say oh you know he allowed this
to happen I said I can only tell you
what I was told privately where you said
Dan I don't know how to get out in front
of this and when I said if you go talk
to the clubhouse guys you're gonna find
out exactly what is going on in baseball
and that's what happened and you you
said it to me on a couple occasions you
know Dan the last 15 years you know you
were right
I spent enormous time with the
professional athletic trainers remember
I ran a team for 25 years so I know they
knew more than anybody going on and I
yes that's true there was no question
about that there was no question about
that and I lived with them and the team
doctors the last 15 years but I still
talk to him a lot of money come to town
come to Milwaukee they come and see me
and I I'm grateful for that do you think
steroids still play a role in baseball I
asked dr. Gary Greene that a lot because
he's our and he's a leading steroid
expert and he really knows this stuff I
would not sit here today and tell you no
but I really believe we have cleaned it
up George Mitchell made 20
recommendations we cleaned Club I talked
to a lot of a lot of people in the game
yet and they're convinced
very very very little my best to the
family commissioner and thank you very
much for joining us great to talk to you
again thank you Dan as always I really
enjoy talking to you and I look forward
to seeing you soon for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]